pendant que le pays est submergé par la
pandémie un nombre croissant d'indiens
espère se faire vacciner dans le plus
grand hôpital de mumbai créé l'an passé
pour traiter les patients infectés par
la commune 19 on inocule plus de 5000
personnes par jour c'est bien en deçà de
la capacité maximale de sept mille doses
par jour
une pénurie de vaccins affecte plusieurs
régions du pays pour tenter de freiner
la propagation la ville de mumbai
désinfecte toilettes publiques édifice
résidentiel et une partie des
bidonvilles chaque semaine ça rassure
les gens affirmé cet élu
mumbai est confinée depuis plus de deux
semaines
même les commerces de rue partie
essentielle de la vie dans cette
mégapole de 12 millions d'habitants sont
fermés bon nombre de résidents sont
forcés de se tourner vers les souks
populaires mis sur pied pendant la
pandémie de confinement aggravent les
conditions de vie déjà précaires des
vendeurs de rue et des résidents des
bidonvilles environ 40% de la population
de mumbai vie dans ces bidonvilles
benjamines vient chercher son seul repas
quotidiens dans cette soupe populaire
il était vendeur de petits objets dans
le train de banlieue
maintenant désertées par les
travailleurs confiné
pour prévenir les abus un système de
contrôle d'identité a dû être mis sur
pied pour ceux qui commandent ces repas
populaire gratuit pour remporter photos
et noms sont consignés cet orphelinat de
mumbai aussi a décidé de faire sa part
plus de 200 repas sont distribués chaque
jour sa femme est venue chercher des
repas pour nourrir ses cinq enfants elle
vendait sur la plage des jouets et
ballon mais il n'ya plus de touristes
elle repart en ayant accompli son
objectif quotidien trouver de la
nourriture
pour ceux qui éprouvent des problèmes
physiques ou de santé mentale un livreur
un ange gardien va à leur rencontre
134 millions d'indiens vivre et
maintenant avec moins de deux dollars
par jour
ces 75 millions de plus qu'avant la
pandémie ont réussi à survivre au jour
le jour dit benji men il remercie dieu
chaque fois qu'il peut réussir à manger
un repas chaud ici philippe leblanc
radio-canada mumbai